When I first learned Git, one of the most
confusing topics to me was merge
conflicts. It seems like I always found
myself in a merge conflict I didn't know
why and I didn't know how to get out of
it. But really they're not that
complicated. A merge conflict occurs when
there's been a change in the same file
in the same line on the two branches
you're trying to merge together. So here,
for example, if we're working in index.html on two branches and there have been
changes in line four in both files that will
generate a merge conflict. Now, for
example ,this is just one conflict there
could be multiple files or even multiple
portions of the same file with conflicts
but for now let's keep it simple. So, Git
tells you there's a conflict.
What do you do next? My favorite next
step is to run 'git status'.
It's an easy way to clear my head and
see exactly which files have the
conflicts in them. Once I know what file
to look at, I open it up in my favorite
text editor and I look for these merge
conflict markers. Once you find the merge
conflict markers, all you need to do is
pick the version of code that you'd like
to keep and get rid of the merge
conflict markers. One version will be
above equal signs and the other will be
below. You can pick one, delete them both,
or create something totally new.
Git doesn't care. Just make sure the code
looks the way you want it to and get rid
of the merge conflict markers. Save those
changes and commit them and Git will
know the merge conflict has resolved.